you come live with me and design
everything in my house
yes let's do it
[Music]
this is star talk sports edition neil
degrasse tyson here you're a personal
astrophysicist let me introduce my
co-host chuck nice jack hey what's
happening and i got uh gary o'reilly
gary former soccer pro
i'm neil all right dude and also uh
sports announcer
so gary you cooked up this this episode
so i can't wait to find out what's going
to happen so this show is about smart
engineering right innovative material
science
kick our sportswear design all
converging as i said to help people
recover faster and live longer the link
recover from sports injuries i guess mmm
patience
sorry all right the link to all the
above
is sadly diabetes
wow so we are trapped or are we
in a failing endocrine system the
results are only amputations or is there
a way to walk out of this particular
hell uh let me introduce i'll just say i
see what you did there yeah
kindly ill very good we caught that gary
um it won't happen again
so dr jason hempht the person that chose
to question why
things were not improving with his
patients conditions and then
investigated
he is a foot and ankle surgeon and
clinical podiatrist in miami florida
this is the guy who had the gonads to
then go out and do something about it uh
let me then introduce our second guest
an industrial designer
uh michael dittorlo with a client list
that has included google
nike jordan that'll be the michael
version uh and honda as well as having
been the design director at the
sportswear giant converse winner of the
industrial design society of america
personal recognition award
in 2019. so neil please welcome our two
guests the good doctor jason and michael
well excellent welcome welcome to star
talk guys my gosh wow thank you for
having us yeah so so let me say let me
start out by saying
um
could you just remind us
why diabetes has anything at all to do
with like circulation which ultimately
ends up in amputations because we hear
that it has to do with you know your
metabolism and processing of sugar
and then all of a sudden somebody gets
their legs amputated like what how do
you how do you get from here to there
let's take a half a step back let's talk
about who gets from here to there
so so as of today one in ten americans
this diabetic okay by 2025 it's going to
be one in three
and in three years in three years in
three what correct wow and two out of
those three will be black
so that is not an understatement people
of color and
people uh native americans have a 50
higher chance of
becoming diabetic oh my wow so if you're
looking at you know
hundreds of millions of people around
the world becoming diabetic yeah um
once they've had diabetes the
fluctuations in blood sugar affect the
myelin the covering of the nerves
and the nerves that are farthest from
your central nervous system your brain
have the longest amount of myeloma so
this tissue because of fluctuations in
blood sugar gets thicker and thicker and
the electrical impulse cannot be
conducted so they develop what's called
peripheral neuropathy
loss of feeling in the hands and feet
and this isn't if you step on a nail you
can't seal it this is small amounts of
pressure you can't heal
so here you have this large group of
people who lose the feeling in their
feet and they get small amounts of
pressure over time a shoe rubbing a sock
balled up
an inappropriate fitting shoe
this cuts off the local circulation
leading to a wound
of all the wounds that occur in the u.s
roughly 3 million a year
85 percent of those will become infected
within six weeks
that's the pathway to amputations once
you violate the tissue envelope
diabetic patient bacteria get in and
that's the pathway to these 120 000 plus
amputations a year so jason so
specifically what are what are the most
common symptoms
the typically they have no symptoms okay
because they have no feelings also
that's what i was going to ask
i read that the myelin is like a i don't
know like a conductor it allows the
electrical impulses to run you know
travel up your spinal cord and whatever
so if that stops or slows down you just
you're not feeling anything that
correct so typically the only time that
people present with the wound is when
someone visualizes it they don't know
they have it until they either look
which most people can't see the bottom
of their foot
or someone else looks at their foot
is this nerve damage repairable
or is this right one way street
right now there's no cure for diabetic
peripheral neuropathy there are
adjuvant therapies vitamins
etc and there are
medicines to manage the symptoms but
there is nothing to bring back the
feeling
wow medical science throws a lot of
resources at a number of problems
has it thrown the resources at this
particular condition
or is this condition just particularly
baffling right now
it's quite baffling resources in the
billions have been thrown at it
including uh genetic modifications gene
therapy
oral medicines injectable medicines
tissue transplants and to date nothing
has worked
wow
well that's our show people thank you so
much
[Laughter]
okay so
allow me to
dare
such a suggestion that
your only solution is for diabetes to go
away
so curing diabetes doesn't cure
neuropathy even if you have patients who
have peripheral neuropathy no no no no
i'm saying no no no no i'm i'm
i'm saying
preventing diabetes in the first place
eradicating it from the species
puts you out of business is that correct
oh please yes that would be wonderful
okay there you go that's all i'm trying
to say here that
that this is we can try to keep putting
band-aids on a problem when the problem
perhaps should be solved in a different
way rather than bring out all the
band-aids and the
and the hacksaw for your amputations i
mean this that's all i'm saying i'm just
making a simple book say and that's
that's that's the difference between a
truly caring medical professional um and
uh
you know
capitalism
and real the real answer is no neil we
don't want to cure it uh we just want to
find a way you want to keep treating it
yes yeah
find the
walking into your clinic
and with the fact that now they're aware
they have a diabetic ulcer
um and things go wrong
what does the timeline i know you said
it could be six weeks if an
infection so what then is a timeline to
amputation and then what after
amputation are we talking about for
their future if there is going to be one
and how long are we talking about so
this would be just to be clear this
would be an ulcer in one of your
extremities that will go unnoticed and
then gets infected
so this is an ulcer in the foot
typically because the hand amputation
rate is a hundred times less than the
foot amputation rate because you don't
walk on your hand and you can see them
yeah the real issue is the pressure of
walking right once you get a hole the
pressure of walking keeps the wound from
healing it doesn't allow the body's
healing processes or even external
healing processes to take place
seven to 26 times your body weight goes
on the bottom of your foot with every
step so if you're trying to feel a wound
and you can't take the pressure off
low likelihood so to answer your
question about timing um it depends
the extent of when the infection is
identified right if you're at home you
don't know you have a wound you're not
looking at your foot if this infection
is spread to the bone
there's a very high likelihood north of
70 percent that you'll end up losing a
portion and or all of your foot don't
you doesn't the body respond to
infection with a fever and wouldn't that
be a noticeable symptom
so in the non-diabetic or healthy
non-immunocompromised patient fever
redness swelling pain are the signs of
infection
but the diabetic patient is considered
immunocompromised and they don't mount
the same type of response
so it frequently goes unnoticed jason
how many of your patients would you
clinically identify as obese
because
that means that i may not be able to see
my feet
i have been compounding literally
the pressure and weight through my my
lower limbs
and it's built
almost in a perfect way to end in a
destructive
process i mean the perfect storm you're
saying yeah because if you're if you're
morbidly obese or obese in almost on any
category you don't really see the lower
half of your body at all right yeah
so this is absolutely correct there are
two types of diabetes type 1 and type 2
type 2 is by the vast majority
people are overweight
increased bmi so then not only can't
they touch feel the bottom of their feet
they can't see them
and
unfortunately
this is one of the pillars of why
this epidemic has not only
expanded and continues to grow but has
gone
sort of a shameful
mark has been put on it right because
people who are heavy have this
so let me ask you this when since
there's no symptoms we also know that
you're at risk if you are obese
is there any preventative uh
self-diagnostic uh tools that you might
be able to use
to say hey i'm in this risk category now
let me keep an eye on this a foot mirror
that is the simplest answer absolutely
correct with new technologies with
bluetooth enabled maps temperature
sensing maps visualization and
temperature measurement can be done
remotely so you can have a a mat at the
foot of your bed every night you stand
on it it can measure temperature
pressure and report to a cloud where a
medical practitioner can follow up on
that so there's absolutely technology
available to assist but in the simplest
format a mirror on a stick
or a spouse inspecting your feet daily
and and the american diabetes
association recommends regular routine
visual inspection of the foot wow look
at that
low tech and high tech low tech and high
tech yeah
i was going to say it'd be great if it
as a part of you know your regular metal
medical insurance you'll be able to get
some of those uh you know technological
um assistance but then you said mirror
on the stick
it's over
that's what that's what you get
you're like i'd like to avail myself of
some cloud technology they're like
here's a mirror with a stick
so i think chuck it's anything on a
stick that's what it is
that's the real
indication we've got nothing left for
you
for you so
jason we've
we're getting into a medical
universe now that has brain machine
interfaces
and that work and development it would
that be of any use
to this peripheral neuropathy
so
you can stimulate the central nervous
system and you can interface with the
central nervous system and trigger it
but when the wire leaving the junction
box isn't working properly
nothing goes any farther than where that
myelin has been thickened right
right
it's like a jamming signal that's crazy
wow that's an accurate description is
there a chemical
a potential chemical solution once it
thickens to reduce that
there are a number of companies that
have tried to date nothing has been
successful in clinical trials
the best way to keep your myelin then is
to keep your blood sugar under control
so if you don't have these massive
swings of blood sugar
the myelin doesn't get thick
and there's lots of technology for
assisting and keeping your blood sugar
under control continuous glucose
monitoring pumps that in that instill
medications wi-fi communication to
phones vibrating headsets i mean there's
all sorts of
devices available out there to help you
control your sugar all right guys we've
got to take a short break uh when we
come back we're going to find out why
michael dittulo is actually one of our
guests as well
as jason hanft on star talk
we're back star talk sports edition
we're talking about your lower
extremities right your feet and boots
that might be worn over them and we got
with us two guests dr
jason hanft and we bring on in this
segment uh in full force michael ditullo
uh michael
you came in on the other side of this
uh
what
what's your role and what's going on
here how are you trying to make this a
better world thanks neil my background
is as an industrial designer most people
listening probably don't know what an
industrial designer is so know what it
is and you guys are my favorite people
thank you oh my gosh it makes living
not only
helpful but beautiful and chill thank
you chuck we're going to need michael
and neal to get to get on yeah
i was about to say i'm going to have to
turn my camera off
i thought i was neal's favorite person
in the world
yeah
i'm going to make a zoom breakout room
for neil and actually
but
so i explained to people like if you
think of what an architect does for
buildings and what a fashion designer
does for apparel i do that for literally
everything else in your life your your
phone your pen your car your chair for
better for worse everything you touch
was designed by an industrial designer
at some point
and so
uh for me i love working on challenges i
love learning i always say i'm not a
subject matter expert i'm a creative
generalist so i love partnering with
people like jason who are
super passionate and crazy knowledgeable
because i feel like i could pull out of
them some crazy parameters that we can
use to find an innovative solution and
in most cases i mean when you're
you know design is like this fun mix of
science and art and i think when you're
you're putting these two things together
the right solution oftentimes afterwards
seems painfully obvious but it's only
until you get to that that it seems that
way if that makes sense yeah things like
a paper clip i mean there were no paper
clips before somebody invented a paper
clip
exactly so that's probably in the hall
of fame of industrial design
among things so so all right so let's
take a let's take a sample case 400
pound person with diabetes walks in
and
uh and jason has a look and you have a
look at this person now how do you put
your heads together and address what
what's going on here
well when jason came to me about four
years ago the first thing we did was put
together three basic principles one it
has to functionally perform obviously
it is a what
you're right so so we wanted to create
this protective boot
right that would create an environment
where someone's wound could heal right
because if you're walking right if you
if you're a person a normal person
you're gonna still go to work you're
gonna still go to the grocery store so
you can't avoid putting pressure on your
foot so we have to create an environment
that alleviates the pressure so that
someone's wound can actually heal so
that's principle one has to function
principle two it has to be easy to put
on and take off because again we're
dealing with a person with reduced
mobility reduce feeling right so they
have to be able to put it on and off
error free even at two in the morning
when you have to run to the bathroom
real quick and i'm going to channel
chuck here and it has to look fabulous
that's the third principle
the third principle is it couldn't work
if it stays in someone's closet right
right if they feel too ashamed to go to
work in it right um it can't work right
it will fail 100 of the time that it's
not used and listen you know how many
people need orthopedic shoes but they
will not wear them right they're like no
i refuse that is exactly what was going
on here before chuck the devices that
were on the market there are other boots
to protect the foot but people couldn't
or wouldn't use them all because of that
appeal they were not
usable or good looking
right my goal is if you put this on with
a pair of jeans you know it's going to
look as much like a pair of jordans as
you can make it you know so that instead
of going instead of someone saying like
oh what's that i want someone to say oh
what is that oh they're very good right
so okay you mentioned you mentioned
more importantly you want them to say
who is that
what's crazy is that we're building this
out for function right but the world of
fashion you look at like what kanye west
is doing with adidas it's not far off
from where this is going where where a
600 800 pair of balenciagas is uh so
we're kind of like these worlds are kind
of colliding right now all right michael
you mentioned jordan so we'll bring up
the goat
if you wish and i do
you designing specifically for michael
jordan right back in your day now wait a
minute michael jordan has diabetes
do behave
oh come on that was good i know it was
but i don't want to give you any credit
any credit
sorry gary sorry that's okay man so
everything you've designed for him and
every other elite world-class athlete
has
a rise and you are pushing the foot
forward so is the
weight goes through the ball of the foot
so as i can sprint or maybe in this case
michael rather than me yeah so you
offset the heel it's not a
level flat so think of it as a skater's
sneaker it's flat to sit on a skateboard
right right when you've got a sneaker
that's like a a basketball sneaker a
wrench it's raised the heel is raised
you've got to drop that's putting
pressure on the ball of the foot for a
reason so as you can launch forward now
everything you've learned to make
that for those athletes
you have to kind of
pull apart so how do you start to do the
retro fit because you can't put the
pressure through the ball of the foot
surely yeah that's exactly right this is
this is the jordan 22 pe that i worked
on this has got a 10 millimeter drop you
know from the from the heel to the toe a
running shoe might have even more that's
that's pretty common right they're
anatomically like forcing you onto the
balls of your feet which is exactly
where the wounds from a diabetic foot
ulcer are they're typically on the balls
of your feet so so that's you know
that's aggravating those diabetic foot
ulcers and as jason said most folks who
are getting treatment they're they're
leaving the office in their shoe so
they're they're leaving the office in
the product that's aggravating um their
wound so so this product that jason and
i worked on the foot defender has a
slight negative two millimeter heel drop
um it deceptively looks like a footwear
materials but underneath this is a
injection molded brace that goes all the
way around the product and then we've
got a piece of sprung carbon fiber here
so that is really
forcing the geometry of your leg
backwards so you just cannot put
pressure on it
the bottom is also flat so unlike a
sneaker right where you have these these
huge rockers kind of
leading you into and out of the product
by having flat again you can't get out
over onto the balls of the feet so
there's so much kind of geometry and
science that goes into this thing that's
deceptively looks a lot like a shoe
um
that's amazing
yeah
michael i'm sorry to cut you off here
because first of all ingenious design
secondly love the uh the form and
function playing together thirdly and
most importantly
how do you get me jordan's
it's just one
i just guys anyone
else come visit me in uh in portland
chuck we'll take care of you yeah i'm
not that far from campus
you've conquered the bit where the foot
must move but remain rigid you've
redistributed the weight
yeah but in doing that
are you then
the blessing and the curse are you then
creating other
mysteries that you need to solve
in this particular solution
i don't let jason take that so the
answer to your question is yes but
that's where 35 years of biomechanical
analysis comes into play so if you look
at the foot really carefully the mid
part of the foot is a rigid arch
it rarely if ever touches the ground and
it doesn't move
so you now have a structure by which you
can transfer force to without
causing a problem
nice and good this is part of the reason
well this is part of the reason it took
seven years and 39 iterations to get to
the device you're seeing today whereas
once we you know force doesn't disappear
you
can appreciate that
but once
you move force from one place to another
you have to come up with a mechanism by
which to deal with it whether you're
decreasing it by creating
unique materials viscoelastic materials
that rebound and push it in another
direction or you use very rigid
materials to transfer it
up the leg
right so because you're not making this
out of just one
you know one supply of
rubber or plastic
were there commercially available
materials to do this or did you have to
be creative beyond that
so there were some in the footwear world
we used a number of materials that you
would find in
the footwear world you know wicking
anti-friction
foams and and cloth
materials textiles but we were looking
for maximum
impact attenuation right so you have a
400 pound person whose muscles don't
work and nerves don't work so their foot
slapping the ground right much like you
take your hand and just
slam it on the table so we we
looked at 700 different materials to try
and find the best impact reducing
material around
and we then modified it so we
essentially created a new material it's
a viscoelastic polyurethane that we are
calling absorbium that has
wow
that sounds like something you find in
wakanda no yes absorbing it
right that's right you find it right
next to vibranium yeah and
unobtainium is in the same oh no
exactly so
it removes somewhere between 87 and 90
percent of the impact force
um wow just by the mechanical and
material properties well just to be i
hate this to be precise just to be
physics precise i would say but tell me
if i'm wrong that it dissipates the
force rather you are absolutely awesome
okay okay send it someplace else yeah
yeah
but but here's the thing now guys please
don't judge me for this it's just how i
think we do anyway trucks okay good all
right so you're talking about something
that is probably you know the most
prolific shock absorber uh for the foot
in history um
there's a crapload of money in running
shoes for something like this
i mean
are you thinking about that maybe well
in that in some ways it actually does
the opposite right so in a running shoe
you want the foam to rebound really yeah
right do you want you want that force
you don't want to lose the energy
this is a this is a dampener
right so you want a return of energy if
you're running yeah shock absorber
right so this takes i got it there you
go yeah
that's why the blade the blade works so
well because all the energy that you use
to
land on it oh the prosthetic covered
when the thing springs back right so
yeah that's a very different utility
cool michael if we disassembled
this defender boot how many pieces are
there so like you do an engine the
classic take the engine apart and you
lay all the bits out on the on the table
how many pieces are in there because my
guess is this has a ridiculously large
amount of pieces yeah it's probably over
a hundred i mean there's just so many
different things going on inside of this
product i mean
jason talked about that absorbing
material i even just wanted to
aesthetically give you the hint of where
those are right with we talked about the
industrial designer's job to make it
functional but also i want to draw
attention to that function so
there's those two pucks are under the
heel and the forefoot here so kind of
visually telling that story all right
can you hold that up
michael can you hold that up again see
the soul of the shoe right there the
guys
if you're listening to this on the
podcast apologies but that's
like a foot within a foot within a foot
right
what's going on there because that that
you can't tell me that's just cosmetic
because it's on the sole of the foot and
one gets seen so there must be a really
good reason well it is i'm trying to
kind of basically draw the eye inward
because we have a a symmetrical product
here right so it's left and right so
that automatically makes it
aesthetically a little off but i'm
trying to kind of fool the eye to make
it feel
slimmer more acceptable uh you'll notice
like all this traction is kind of
oversized because
you're wearing this inside and outside
and i want kind of dirt and grime to
kind of fall out as easily as possible
but give you this this traction that's
going to give you that kind of the grip
you want
so we're actually using basically a
cupsole
technology so this is like one giant
piece of rubber that's that's very stiff
um that's used in kind of 80s basketball
shoes skate shoes uh it's heavier and
stiffer than a typical outsole but we
want that rigidity right so we're we're
making all these choices to to to to
have functional benefits even these this
little hint of these kind of red
embroidered hits right you don't they
don't need to be there but they tell you
without you having to look at the manual
like this is how you get into and out of
this thing it's called design
it's called design people
so all right so by the way
i gotta interject here i gotta interject
for those who didn't otherwise think
about this i'm not talking to you
michael but chuck or carrie all right
one of the greatest contributions to
this world
that apple computer
gifted us
is not even the computer
it's the fact
that
they made it normal for you to open the
package
and operate something without ever
looking at an instruction manual that's
right intuitively they've
made that uncommon design yeah correct
and i remember growing up okay here's
this box where's the on switch open up
the manual where's the uh where is this
switch what happens if it says this if
it makes this sound it's three flashes
of light what do i do now that we have
people growing up that have never looked
in an instruction manual because of that
i'm just i've got i told you michael i'm
all me and you are tight okay you're
getting in a room
no that and that was my goal of this
right like this person they got a life
to live i don't want them to spend time
reading a technical manual i want them
to just get this thing from their doctor
and be able to put it on
kind of idiot proof i hate that term but
but you know
full proof in terms of just putting it
on correctly uh and not have to read a
manual and to be able to use it and heal
so
michael
the boots open toned
which is great if you live in florida
all year round but you're up there in a
different latitude it's cold and your
foot's cold so how are we are we solving
this problem but then yeah michael that
everyone lives in florida very very
intentional as you would have guessed
right and and jason could speak to this
more but most of folks that that have
this condition right there their foot
might be
not a normal size there might be
swelling it might be wrapped in bandages
um and jason do you want to speak to
that from from your profession sure so
everybody everybody that goes in a foot
defender has an open wound that wound
requires a bandage if you put a closed
toe on it you're now con finding a space
and you'll more likely get a rub or an
area of pressure and it'll be
self-defeating right what we found in
cold temperatures is people are using
really high technology it's called a
sock
you put a cold weather sock and even
available are some uh thermally assisted
socks right they have a battery that can
warm
those very electric socks yeah yeah
they're totally toasty okay so just just
so our audience and i can remember jason
you're based where where are you now
south florida
oh and michael
portland oregon opposite corner oh
portland oregon okay you got it but it's
never really subfreezing in portland
right it's always just
it's just cold and dank
yeah get a little snow but but not much
yeah yeah okay so that's where the miami
connection is coming in you're in south
miami jason right correct correct yeah
yeah all right let's take a quick break
when we come back more on this sort of
diabetic boot solution that might
prevent amputations which is something
we would all want uh when star talk
continues
we're back star talk sports edition
we've got dr jason
and michael de tullo
jason is a
is a surgeon
who unfortunately is confronted with
having to amputate uh many a lower
extremity from uh complications from
diabetes and michael ditullo is figuring
out how to not make that happen and we
need more folks like this walking among
us in the world
uh so let's let's just pick up the
conversation um with this with this boot
are we to say here
that
if you have a sore that develops on the
bottom of the feet from complications
from diabetes
this boom will allow it to heal and do
diabetics heal
the way
non-diabetics do like on the same time
frame and do they respond to the same
topical medicines this sort of thing
really interesting question so
the the best way i can
give you the answer to that is diabetics
don't do anything the same as
non-diabetics but we do know that
we do know that diabetics have the
ability to heal because wounds elsewhere
in their bodies don't lead to an
amputation every 20 seconds and that's
in the united states every 20 seconds
someone in the u.s is losing their leg
to the complication of a diabetic
fidelity
wow that's that is disturbing yes
it's something we don't talk about right
it's like because because like jason
said there's this shame associated with
it that someone feels like they're at
fault it's you hide it you hide your
wound in your shoe you don't show
anybody and so i think a big part of
what we're trying to do is just
get this out into the open and be like
hey there's no shame in this let's fix
it i i love that because you know this
is one of the diseases that we often
refer to as a lifestyle
malady and so the moment you add
lifestyle to
the description of the of the problem it
makes it seem like well you did this to
yourself you know it's like lung cancer
people are far less likely to have
compassion for a person with lung cancer
like oh you shouldn't have smoked yes
interesting point interesting point so
um
michael maybe you can answer this
you would have traditionally gone to
a medical device
uh equipment manufacturer
to do this but you turned around
because you weren't getting the results
you wanted and went to a shoe factory
am i right and why
what was what was not being delivered to
you
that you could get with a shoe factory
we struggled for for two years you know
we're we're working with uh
some some medical device makers
to hit the performance targets but we we
couldn't get the fit and finish that
made it feel like an acceptable consumer
product that made it feel like you could
get it at slitlocker to be short
and so finally we had a we were having a
brainstorm session in in my my studio
jason and i and i was like you know
maybe we're just thinking about this
totally wrong we were we were working
with a medical factory we were exposing
all the hard plastic parts and it just
was a real challenge to make it look
right and then every time we wanted to
make a change to tweak the performance
like massive tooling cost i was like
let's start thinking about this less
like a medical device and more like a
technical shoe that has to do something
and i think we'll be able to train a
footwear factory how to make something
with our technical parameters a lot
easier than it would be to train a
medical factory how to sew something
like this um so that's what led to
hiding all of the technical parts you
could just see these little little peaks
of it you could see a tiny peak into the
carbon fiber here
we exposed it subtly but by hiding all
of it
we could
create this nice piece of footwear and
then as we were prototyping and testing
all different internal braces we can
make all those changes internally until
we got the spec exactly right and then
confirm that with the factory and now we
just check to make sure they're they're
executing it exactly to the
specification will you come live with me
and design everything in my house
yes let's do it
do you do it all are you do will you do
something as simple as like a michael
graves teapot or something no no he's if
you're doing that everything in front of
you is subject to your
scrutiny
i did this i did this watch you know so
there's no escaping it yeah so michael
you've incorporated you've incorporated
a pump
into this boot haven't you now for those
of us of a certain vintage
flashback to what was it late 80s early
90s yeah 80s with the reebok you've got
reebok retro with a with a high top pump
in that wait let me just remind people
so was it reebok there was a pump pump
it up where it was a high-top sneaker oh
that's that that had an air bag in it
where you'd put on the sneaker lace it
up but maybe it didn't fit perfectly in
all places so it had a pump on it which
filled the gaps with air so that your
entire foot would be more
um uh smooth ugly snugly fit snugly fit
was that the inspiration michael well
you didn't really see it it was like six
months i think neil you let you took my
whole description from me but yeah you
guys
i was just i was just getting people up
to speed so we can now listen to you
it's awesome no then so jason was like
hey maybe we should uh put this put a
pump in it to to fill the gaps right
exactly like you nobody's two legs are
exactly the same
even though it's it fits great and
performs well there could be this
feeling of gaps so you you fit it up and
then you pump up the rest and now you're
you're basically just pushing the
internal uh sleeve in constant contact
with the body so you get this
proprioceptive effect uh that you feel
much more secure so the bladder the air
bladder would fill in where it needs to
and not fill in where it can't
but yes because it's you know it's a
totally custom fit and then the bladder
is basically shaped like a pair of lungs
so so uh there's basically two chambers
uh it hovers over your heel so you're
kind of really locking the heel into
place you know so again we don't want to
cause any more injuries so any kind of
repetitive movement inside is a
potential for more injuries chris rock
was the lead
performer in a saturday night life skit
uh back when that reebok sneaker was
popular and it was thanksgiving dinner
and it was in the spirit of the pump of
the reap rock you they now sold turkeys
that you could pump up
so the turkey had a little pump and you
could make it bigger if you had more
people coming for thanksgiving
just look that one up on google that you
should be able to find it right so the
other the other important and functional
part of the pump is is not only fit but
you can imagine if you're trying to
control
forces
and the heel is pistoning up and down as
the person walks because it's a rigid
device
if you don't lock the heel in you're
going to load the front of the foot so
it really it's all about this decreasing
the pressure on the front of the forces
on the front of the foot because that's
where 88 percent of the wounds have
so how wide spread is this product right
now uh it's available everywhere in the
united states we're shipping to other
countries we really had our first
product launch uh in april commercially
very
you've learned lessons from this i could
obviously it's taken more than five
minutes to bring it from a clean sheet
of paper to
this what is it a calorie one medical
device
what lessons have you learned along the
journey and have you applied those then
to new products
um i don't think this show has enough
time for all the lessons we've learned
our entire team has has learned lessons
because we're doing things that no one's
done before nobody has built the medical
device for the lower extremity that is
patient-centric right everything we did
is built so that a patient will want to
use it because you know if you had
rocket boots and patients wouldn't wear
them what good are they
so you've got rocky birds
working on it oh by the way not not to
beat a dead horse but in the early days
of the pc wars between ibm and apple
apple did not have much entry into the
business world because ibm was already
there and apple got great inroads into
the art world so then how's apple going
to reach the business world so they had
a commercial
where
um there's an apple pc there was a mac
and it there was a early in the mac and
then there's an ibm pc and and the two
executives are looking at it and they
say which one is more powerful the apple
or the ibm pc and then the person
answers
uh the one that's more powerful is the
one that people want to use it was a
line of people waiting for that's the
apple
the message i love that and there was
like one person on the ibm
that's all it is that's that whole
principle we're using it we don't then
it's useful
we don't claim to be the perfect
pressure reducing device but we really
are a pressure reducing device that
people can easily get on and off
and one of the things we discovered
along the way was michael and i and some
other engineers spent a long time on
this front spat the interior brace that
michael showed you earlier and how it
almost auto closes you pull off three
tabs open it like a book and then you
let go and it falls back on itself so
it's really easy to do but what we found
was patience
about the first 50 to be exact 49 out of
50
adjusted it once
put it on and off like a cowboy boot
they just slid their foot in slid it out
they leave it by their bed at night they
don't have to adjust anything they just
slide their foot right in
and the device isn't designed to fit
skin tight it's designed to
fit
it's small medium and large so
uh that's also where the pump part comes
in handy so if you're in between sizes
it'll help but with the device on and
adjusted appropriately it doesn't have
to hug you tight or reduce circulation
okay so michael jason just jason just
opened up a whole nother product line
here which is you make this out of
ostrich skin
and other common leather uh
cowboy boots
you can start a whole new style oh man
right yeah whole new market
you're a corner of the texas market
yeah
so the the other learnings we found in
all of our business has been built on
what patients have told us we took we
essentially pulled 5000 patients and
said why aren't you using the devices
you have and the first answer was i
can't the second answer was this stigma
i can't go to work and do it and the
third one was when i get home i need to
take my device off because it's dirty
from being out in the world so here are
these people that are protecting their
foot all day they come home and they
walk around in a sock or a flip-flop or
a slide
and there's data out there that shows
you actually walk more at home than you
do at work for most people
so here they are
all day being diligent then they come
home
and put their body weight times seven or
more on their foot all night long so
what the patients told us was they
wanted something protected to use at
home instead of socks or slides
um okay so michael what'd you what did
you you heard about that and then what
did you do yeah so i thought of like if
we could think of the foot defender as
like our f1 car right this is where
we're to do all our research that's one
formula one car listen to you yeah oh my
god yes so this is where we're doing all
of our r d right how can we take that
down into like the bmw m3 that someone
could drive to work every day right so
we developed this product the cloud9 i
drive my f1 to work every day
you get a ticket every day
my 12 year old dream but um
so this is all the same material science
that went into the foot defender but
this is something someone could wear
at home or when they don't need the foot
defender anymore or
maybe before they even need the foot
defender if we could get them ahead of
time into something like this we're
going to launch it in a bunch of
different colors
um and it's just something you could
rock around the house really comfortably
i would totally wear that
no matter what there you go yeah that is
just like a super but so you look like
something
wait what's the difference between that
and like clogs
it's the same architecture right the
same form factor yeah it looks very uh
netherlands-y right yes but but
internally we've got all the same
material stack that's inside the foot
defender so that absorbium uh those two
absorbium pucks there's like how thick
is that insole jason like 22 millimeter
yeah 30 millimeter insole so it
literally feels like you're walking on
cloud9 uh and then the last we developed
so you just be clear cloud nine was a
cloud
rating system
that at where the ninth of the in the
system was uh a cumulative cumulus cloud
which included cumulonimbus clouds the
puffiest of the clouds so that led to
the tradition of saying i'm on cloud
nine because you don't want to be on
cloud seven because that's like cirrus
clouds and you know other whatever
that's where angels go to die
okay
i actually never knew the origin of that
yeah
was the cumulus puffy a cotton cloud in
the sky so jason before we have to wrap
all of this up sadly um
130 000 amputations in the us each year
how many do you estimate you could
possibly take out of that good good
question
with this boot and this footwear so
imagine if we could get this our
technology on 10 of that number each one
of those amputations cost the health
care system half a million dollars each
one each one what
the price of the amputation isn't for
the surgery it's not aesthetic it's for
the rehab of the patient
right
for the it's for everything the health
care of that patient and by the way the
mortality rate at five years
for these amputated diabetics is 50
damn so it's higher than most cancers so
you go from amputation to five years of
50 percent mortality rate correct oh my
goodness so the whole idea behind our
business the whole idea behind the foot
defender and its offshoots is stopping
that
moment of tipping from treating a wound
to a mortal amputation right
so can you talk to us about price point
because it seems as though that might be
an important factor i looked online and
there's like crap boots for like 60
dollars and then there's like
these super
like high-tech looking boots for
400
and everything in between
so we're
the
we are a approved reimbursable code by
insurance the code is l4361 it it pays
on average around the country around 295
dollars for reimbursement so we're
selling to doctors and medical
distributors um they fix their own
prices our current retail price is right
in the middle of the range you just
talked about it 250 dollars okay
is that cheaper than modern air jordans
isn't that cheap
shoes at this point in time yeah
that is just tremendous on every level
congratulations guys yeah you guys
congratulations you know it's it's
possible to to put design and science
together and and try to save the world
didn't that tell you on the top nil the
sporty verse
trying to find a solution to this
problem exactly exactly
well michael jason thank you for being
guests on star talking yeah uh you've
enlightened us and you've enlightened
our our audience and we look forward to
the end of an entire category of
amputations because nobody wants to lose
any part of their body at any time all
right so you guys have a website or
something that people can dial in on
absolutely footdefender.com
okay that's clean and simple enough
excellent and michael do you have like a
design page or something where i can
just hang out on it and yeah
you can just go to uh michael
ditullo.com or if you're on instagram uh
um
the letter d the number two l o d two
low phonetically uh oh okay yeah i see
he designed that yeah i see that
design your own damn name yeah
all right guys this uh and gary chuck
always good to have you there always a
pleasure pleasure i love this topic and
gary keep digging up these topics oh
yeah it's coming out of your out of your
satchel yeah
you know we've got a production team and
uh
we're going to keep mining and hopefully
we can find people of this quality and
uh go forward let's keep doing it all
right neil degrasse tyson here as always
keep looking up
[Music]
you